ilan people want to know what is your
morning routine at what time do you get
up normally in the morning of me it's
usually about two seven seven okay but I
go to bed late so usually it's I go to
bed around 1 a.m. oh so why yeah and you
start day with a real breakfast or just
for the coffee or with the water you
know that also varies a lot I think it's
probably true that if you that having a
good breakfast is is a good idea but
usually I don't have time for that so
sometimes sometimes it's it's made for
me but probably half the time I don't
have any breakfast
I had to let's have like coffee or
something like that one spot sure well I
try to cut down on it on sweet stuff so
but I think I mean I think I probably
should have like a an omelet and a
coffee or something like that that seems
like probably the right thing and
sometimes that you have that thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what you thought of this video what
do you think of Ilan's morning routine
does yours look similar
what is your morning routine look like
what advice you have to share about
morning routines leave in the comments
below and I will join the discussion I
also want to give a quick chatter -
Tracy Pittman Tracy thank you so much
for buying a copy of my book really
means a lot to me those you watching if
you want your chains at a future shout
out in a video make sure to get the book
but also email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon